well I've just balanced a whole lot of
Domino's up and what I wanted to do is
look at how computers actually do maths
for us how on earth can a mechanical
system like just a chip in a computer
how can it actually do arithmetic this
is my input Domino here if I bump the
input Domino it's going to send a signal
down the chain and normally you just
have a one single chain of dominoes so
I've mixed it up by well initially
splitting the chain which in itself is
not that controversial but then the
shorter arm over here knocks out some of
these dominoes so if these dollars come
toppling over it'll bump these two out
and this won't be able to cross so in
fact this is a circuit that stops itself
if I bump this and it starts going this
will get their first knock them out this
will come to a halt these are my output
dominoes this is the kind of the output
from the circuit that will not fall over
if I now have two inputs so if I only
knocked over this second input all it
would do is these dominoes would all
fall over it would bump these out and
then it would stop I think what happen
so it means individually either one of
these bumped by itself that Domino will
not fall over
in fact if I don't bump either of these
that Domino will not fall over so if I
knock both of them together this shorter
one here will come along and knock these
out this one at the same time will be
coming along it will split but when this
one gets here these dominoes already
gone so it stops which means these
dominoes don't move this one will go all
the way around it comes along here comes
down here straight across and then out
so this circuit the output only falls
over if and only if I bump both of these
and so we call this an end circuit it's
got two inputs I have to knock over one
of them and the other one to get an
output until I do knocking none of them
first there you go that worked
now that the boring one is just this
input because it will just knock that
out and stop
fun one is either just this one so it
stops itself or both of them so the
signal goes through what would you would
you like I think on behalf of the
viewers they're going to want to sleep
both are you ready here we go one and
the other there you are
so that worked so we've got an output
because I did one and the other one this
is a working and circuit now we can
describe this mathematically so we're
not quite adding numbers yet but it's a
good step in the right direction so
we'll call this one input one and I'm
going to label that one there input one
right here can be input two so that's
input two and then over here we have the
output so I'll label that output and
what I'm going to say is if a Domino is
standing up then nothing's happened yet
we call that a zero if it falls over
we'll say it's becoming a one so if you
don't the first input doesn't fall over
the second input doesn't fall over the
output in theory should not fall over if
input one falls over but input two
doesn't the output won't fall over if
input 1 doesn't fall over but input two
does the output still won't fall over
and then finally if both of these fall
over together the output falls over and
we call that this is the logic table and
so this is what's called an end actually
leveled up here this is a and gate so
what I'm going to try and build next is
a thing called an exclusive all or XOR
which is the the best name of a gate you
have input one we're going to have input
two we're going to have our output again
this time again if I don't touch any of
the inputs I don't want the output to
fall over now if I only bump input one
but not two I still want the output to
follow this input one has to go through
the circuit if I don't hit one but I do
hit two I still want the output to fall
over and then controversially if I bump
both of them together I want them to
somehow cancel out in the circuit so
nothing comes out and that's why it's
called an exclusive or it's one input
all the other input but not both that's
the exclusive bit so I
try and build an exclusive or circuit
out of dominoes give me give me a second
here
there we go so this is my exclusive or
gate and as you can see if you bump over
just input one it'll come flying in here
it goes into the fork here it will come
along this way it will then go out here
we don't carefully thing comes back up
the circuit that's fine more importantly
a comma on this way around there and
then out and likewise because the
symmetric if I bump input to that goes
along into the fork goes along the
middle comes around here and then out at
the output so either one by itself will
make it through the circuit importantly
though if I bump them both
simultaneously they will be using the
centre at the same time they will
collide and stop and the output won't
fall over I quite like the doing both
together right because that's the
difficult bit because anyone can make a
circuit where both inputs lead to the
same output I mean that's easy one where
that happens and they can stop each
other that's where it gets fun so I'm
going to give it a go unfortunately
dominoes do fall over quite quickly and
you want to have as much time as
possible to enjoy the experience so what
we might do is put on some ridiculous
lights and do the whole thing in slow
mode ok right ok that that should be
adequate light so we'll get this going
and in theory they will cancel out right
in the center ok here we go one and the
other one yes
okay so you see this guy is dangerously
close to going so when this collided
there was a bit of recoil back up but
thankfully again not quite enough to
bump these off coming the other
direction so there you are the
exclusive-or together they didn't get
through so we've done the and gate and
made that work with on the exclusive or
gate that's worked what we're going to
do now is go another step in the
direction of ridiculous we're going to
have input one again we're going to have
input two we're then over here we have
the output now again these are our
standard options that we have every time
they're all four ways you can bump over
to inputs now I'm going to have output 1
and output 2 output 1 is going to act as
if it was an end gate so we'll have that
happening output 2 is going to act as if
it is an exclusive or gate and what that
means is if you can have both of these
outputs for those two inputs these are
counting the number of inputs that get
bumped so this is like a units called
this is the ones column and that's twos
so if you only bump one input over the
one output goes if you bump both the
moment you get the twos column goes and
so this is a very very basic circuit
that can count it can tell if you bump
just one or two as a matter which bump
it can still count it so if I repurpose
because it needs an exclusive or in the
middle if I'm very carefully this is
called a binary half adder and the
reason it's called a binary half adder
is it's doing half of what you need to
do full binary of wisps full binary
arithmetic so if you can build what's
called a binary full adder which believe
me we'll get to in a second then you can
do all the calculations you want so a
binary full adder is what calculators
uses more computers use it's the basis
of all automated computation all right
so I'm almost finished I'm putting the
last two dominoes in over here
really you know well this this was
interesting because this chain splits
off and all it does is exact some
forwards for a while and the reason I
had to go and do these extra just on
that right the reason I had to do these
extra Domino's is because this is a
delay line so I need to give because you
can still see the exclusive-or is in
here I need to give the exclusive-or
enough time to do its thing before this
signal catches up with it so this is
just delaying one of the signals the way
this works is if I just bump this input
of first of all if I bumped none of the
inputs perfect if I just want this input
it will come in here goes into the fork
goes across the exclusive-or comes out
the other side this waist signal just
comes back and out that doesn't matter
goes around here goes around there and
then it goes out the unit's output so
that means that one input was bumped if
I bump this one now this is where it
gets slightly more complicated here it
splits and then one signal goes through
the exclusive all the way through out
the other side comes around comes here
splits goes out this the units output
also it blocks these so this fork so
this one stops this chain meanwhile the
other signals coming along here it gets
to here and it's stopped so either one
by itself only that output falls over if
I bump them together well this one
splits again that one goes that way this
one's coming in they collide in the
middle and stop this one carries on its
merry path gets right to the end goes
straight out that output and this one
falls over but that one doesn't and so
that's the twos output and so that's the
binary number that counts how many of
these dominoes I bump this this is a
circuit of anatomy objects that can
count that excites I get
disproportionately excited people say oh
I know I want to have computers work and
they mean you know I want to know how to
use Microsoft Word or I want to know you
know all proven programming languages
here we go I learned to program that or
people go you know what I do everything
from the terminal prompt all right but
you're still just interacting with the
software level of the computer what's
actually
how is the computer actually executing
what you're telling it to do and write
down the very bottom this is the
absolute fundamental layer of all
computing is a circuit of objects that
can make decisions based on inputs all
right so I'm going to bump just this one
only that will fall over that won't move
here we go ready
the system works look at that so it is
able to stop this one from coming
through the exclusive all work perfectly
this came through without being stopped
when out there's our units output this
one didn't move if all you saw was this
you would know that back here I only
bumped one input not too
all right so that worked now as I said
all right this is just the half adder we
want a binary full adder and to have a
full adder you need to have three inputs
so you'll have input 1 input 2 and input
3 and so now we need every single
combination of there's not bumping all
of them is doing that is doing that is
pumping those is pumping that one but
not those there's that one that one that
one that one that one that one okay
there else that's all eight ways you can
have three different inputs falling over
and now I'm going to label this this is
going to be our tunes column and this is
going to be our ones units columns this
is our binary counting of how many we
bump so there we've bumped none of them
there will bump just one just one two of
them one of them two of them two of them
at the very end three of them and to
have three we would expect that to
happen so if we could build this circuit
we would have the full binary adder and
you can build this right so all you need
is basically you chain together two half
adders which is why that's called the
half adder so a little bit of careful
positioning you a lot of dominoes at
this point maybe two or three thousand
dominoes to make this work reliably you
could make a massive circuit which does
this and once you can do that you can
then add any binary numbers together
that you want shall we do a calculation
so what it's going to give me two
numbers in you know between 20 and 50
what should we do
let's do 42 yeah of course and second
time okay so right so we're going to add
42 to 17 bit of a spoiler alert
we're expecting 59 just so we're all I
mean don't you know
for anyone but okay so I'm going to turn
these into binary numbers so 42 is going
to be 32 which means I need another 10
so 32 no 16s 1 8 no fours a21 and then
down here 17 is 0 1 0 0 0 1 so that's 42
and 17 in binary and so now ah and
they're incredibly boring numbers to add
in binary all right
no because if I go along and add them
together what 0 plus 1 is 1 1 plus 0 is
1 0 plus 0 1 plus 0 0 plus 1 and 1 so at
no point did you have having to add two
ones together alright so that made the
sum let me just you know that's what we
get for choosing random numbers but we
can double check the system works
because now that's a fillet well that's
units twos fours 8 16 32 s our answers
are 32 and a 16 which gives us 48 plus
another 8 which gives us 56 plus a 2
which gives us 58 plus 1 which gives us
59 so there so that is 59 in binary
right so the system works what could
have happened though it let's just
rigged it with some interesting binary
numbers right if I had let's say 1 1 0 1
1 1 and I'm adding it to 0 1 1 0 1 1
right so I've deliberately lined up
loads of ones to get in the way because
now if I do 1 plus 1 the answers to and
I can't write a 2 down there because
it's binary but what I can do is I can
write the 0 and carry the 1 and so now
I've got to add three of these together
so I've got to add ok 1 plus 1 plus 1 is
3 so I write the 1 carry the 1 ok 1 plus
1 is 2 2 put that down there
and every single time the only OOP such
misery the only option I can have is
either I'm only ever adding combination
of 3 ones and zeros so no matter how big
the numbers are I want to
I never have to do anything more
complicated than three ones and zeros
and this is every single option so the
reason that binary is great for adding
is when you're adding base 10 numbers
you might have to add a 2 to a 7 or a 1
to a 4 and a 2 it there's so many
options that you may have to add binary
only those 8 options if you can do all
of those you can add any numbers
together by just doing that one step
over and over and over and over and over
again so if you can build that out of
dominoes
that's one bit of the calculation so if
you built this I don't know four times
so if you had you'd probably need about
10,000 dominoes if you had 10,000
dominoes you could build the full adder
circuit four times in a row it means you
could take two four digit binary numbers
as inputs and you could have the five
digit sum coming out as the answer of
course I mean you'd have to be truly
insane to phone up a series of Domino
manufacturers find a wholesaler who
would ship you 10,000 dominoes find a
concrete floor at the well at the Museum
of Science and Industry in Manchester
and then spend an entire weekend
balancing done I may have done this I
got some friends together we got $10,000
and we built a circuit which will add
four digit binary numbers and give you a
five digit answer so if you'd like to
see Matt's giant Domino computer in
action there'll be a link on the screen
and in the video description
it's obviously well worth a look there's
also more of my interview with Matt
where he talks about how you take this
Domino idea he's just explained to the
next level it'll probably be unlisted so
having watched this video for so long
you're in a very exclusive club that
will know about it and finally I'm sure
some of you will be saying in the
comments why isn't this video on
computer file well it probably could
have been but here it is on numberphile
those of you who aren't wondering that
because you've never heard of computer
file allow me to take this opportunity
to tell you about computer file which is
kind of like the sister channel of
numberphile all about computer science
and those sort of things it's well worth
a look
and again I'll include links there's
going to be loads of links under this
video so why don't you sort of extend it
and make that information box a little
bit bigger and you can see them all
sitting